right right
but we got benny here burden of proof is
officially out
and damn hey look man you i feel like
yes sir
the whole crew has been active all year
but you just kind of saved all the ammo
for like the fourth quarter
yeah man i just to be honest with you
because i'm always honest that's
only where i know to be i would have i
would have been put the album out but
it was just so dope that we wanted to
find a home for so we could do something
extra with it so we could do something
special with it
we want to line everything up with it so
that's why we held on to it but we could
have been put this [ __ ] out and i'm
saying
it was a business decision you know what
i'm saying talk about um
because i i was i went to a couple of
the sessions um
when you and hit were working at chalice
on this project
and i remember when hit find like he
told me like nah we're gonna do like a
whole
situation and i didn't even realize like
hit i knew hit boy was like i mean of
course
all-time great producer he's been a
friend of mine for a lot of years but
like
he really got in in his bag like on some
[ __ ] that like
we probably ain't used to hearing him on
like how did the
like the chemistry and the relationship
start with you and hit boy
oh man so just by him reaching out to me
and telling me to come through let's
work already gave me an idea what type
of person he was
yeah you what i'm saying because he
didn't have to do that right right
because this was like
late last year yeah so i come out
uh just kicking it with him i'm saying
he you know he you know him i'm saying
he's
great i'm very humble exactly and i'm
kind of like the same way
and i'm saying so it was like it was
like the synergy was just there you know
what i mean i i enjoy working with him i
love the direction he gave me when we
working on these records i like working
with like producers
instead of like just the beat makers and
i'm saying i i fed off his energy and
i'm saying he got like
i'm coming through i'm seeing rappers do
their [ __ ] oh yeah everybody be up in
there
like oh [ __ ] see grizzlies here and then
big sean is there yeah i mean right
they ain't going right right right right
uh nice
crazy i bumped into a whole lot of
people there so it's like okay
i like this energy i'm kennedy my boy he
always chillin through there you know
what i'm saying so
that type of energy there you know i
i like that